I think we're alive people all right so
I wanted to do a live impromptu YouTube
stream I'm doing this thing off my
computer here today because I've got a
gajillion things going on and my mic
director is not here today so normally
when I do things from the studio as you
guys know my my Studios in my home so
we're in my garage and one of the
bedrooms over there is the control room
and I've done some behind the scenes
things that we used to do on patreon
where I'd give people a tour of the
control room is one of the bedrooms one
of the bedrooms is the is the green room
this this is the garage in here and
we've really turned my entire house into
into a pretty full functioning
state-of-the-art studio it's actually
pretty awesome because when I get major
TV stars that come in here they're like
holy [ __ ] like you've done it man you
created like a real-deal studio it's
pretty awesome
but anyway there's so many things going
on I just flew in from Cleveland this
morning we did a livestream by the way
last night from ocon in Cleveland we did
a live from on big tech Censorship which
had been planned already in a couple
days in advance and then this whole
project Veritas thing went down and I
think we did a really fantastic
conversation with Brian our mirrage
who's a former facebook engineer and
you're on Brook who's the chairman board
at the iran institute and greg salieri
who's a philosophy professor at rutgers
anyway we did I was in front of about
four or five hundred people a live show
and we livestream that there were some
issues with the live-streaming and had
nothing to do with my guys on our end
there were some technical problems over
there so we took down the livestream
we're gonna re-upload it in about two
hours I think at 4:45 Pacific it'll be
re uploaded and we do about a two-hour
conversation with a live Q&A where we
play some of the project Veritas video
we talk about all of the issues related
to tech censorship and you know really
the four of us are small government
people so talking about can competition
fix this are there antitrust issues here
regulation issues all of those things
that you guys know that I've been I've
been talking about relentlessly anyway
so that'll be up in about two hours and
I just wanted to talk directly to you
guys because there's a lot of [ __ ] going
on right
now and it's it's a little nuts it's all
good I did get a haircut today I'm
feeling very good about the hair by the
way I came right right right in from
from Cleveland went right to the to the
barber got the haircut I will be on
Tucker Carlson tonight by the way
talking about the project Veritas thing
I think I'll be on the second segment
that's about 8:00 10:00 p.m. Eastern
so 5:10 p.m. Pacific but I wanted to
just share some thoughts directly to you
guys so quickly just technically if I
could just do one thing real quick which
is that one of the things we're learning
beyond the censorship stuff that I'm
obviously going to talk about here is
that there is a lot of confusion
generally and I think it's partly
intentional on youtubes behalf about how
the algorithm works and how you guys
even when you subscribe to a channel
actually don't see videos and why you
don't see the videos so if you are
subscribed to this channel one of the
things that you have to do is you have
to click the bell that's on the homepage
youtube.com/scishow burn report and
click get all notifications or whatever
that says they're all notification
something like that because otherwise
they just choose not to show you things
and it's particularly confusing now I
get it they unsubscribe people and now
we're learning about all sorts of
suppression and all that but if you want
to get notified of our videos the best
way to do it is to click that bell they
may still screw with you but at least
make sure you've done done that part and
I see already some of you guys in the
comment section saying that you click
the bell all notifications and you still
get nothing so look this is all the
stuff we're trying to figure out this is
what some of the insiders are sharing
with people and you know I'm very torn
here as a limited government guy and
someone that doesn't want regulation
about what we're supposed to do but I'm
gonna keep bringing on experts and and
people with interesting thoughts to talk
about about these companies about
whether they should be regulated are
they platform publishers all of those
issues so I thought today though we do
something a little different so since I
am on my computer I'm a little flexible
here so first off I just want you to all
say hello to Emma we'll give a little a
little hello there to Emma she is the
guard dog of the Rubin report studio
Emma what's going on sister are you
doing lady
you guys I think most of you have
probably heard the story about Emma she
turned 15 two days ago
and she actually she has bladder cancer
which we found out about four months ago
she's she's really doing great right now
and and we're really happy for her she's
on she's on CBD and mushrooms and food
she's a little tired at the moment but
she's really doing great and you know
you guys have said so many sent me so
many nice messages and people have sent
me all sorts of of advice and things to
put her on we don't ever on any any
traditional medication just CBD and some
mushrooms and and some supplements and
things and she's lost some weight and
she's she's doing good she's doing good
and trust me 15 dog years what's that
that's like 105 like if I'm doing that
good at 105 you know and I have people
care and caring for me the way the way
we're cared for I'll feel good so I
thought one of the things that would be
interesting today is because because
people seem to think that I am leading
people to the far right or the alt-right
it's because people think that I'm doing
this sort of thing I thought it'd be
funny I was just sitting here right
before the livestream and you know we
all of the books that I have on set are
former guests of the Rubin report I
thought very quickly these are in no
particular order we just sort of put
them up so kind of based on color pretty
much and I thought we'd kind of look at
the books together and think is this a
show that's leading people to the far
right so let's let's take a look and see
what we've got here
so I'm just gonna do this in order so
Steven Pinker who is a lefty liberal
progressive professor at Harvard
University enlightenment now he's been
on the show this is Amy Chua she wrote a
book called political tribes Amy is
Tiger mom I guess you could probably
describe her I think she's probably
within the classical liberal maybe a
little more conservative milieu but you
know somewhere somewhere sort of
centrist probably a little left-leaning
the way equal is unfair by John Watkins
and you're on Brook who both been on the
show now these guys are Objectivist
they're Iran guys and if you're not
familiar with that they're basically
sort of what you'd call extreme
libertarians they always want to find a
private solution to everything they
don't think the government's pretty
particularly good at anything but there
so this is that you could call that a
far-right position but it has nothing to
do with racism it has nothing to do with
bigotry or anything like that
I love talking about those ideas with
them I disagree on some stuff but it's
all good this is zero to one by Peter
teal Peter teal of course who's been on
the show is a tech entrepreneur and the
co-founder of a PayPal and now he runs
Palantir and the teal I think it's a
teal foundation and a whole bunch of
other things and he's become a good
friend of mine certainly not a far-right
maniac whatever you want to call him
he's kind of basically a libertarian
Neil Ferguson who was one of my favorite
guests actually yeah I know none of this
should matter I see some of the comments
none of this you matter but I'm just I'm
just painting a little picture here Neil
Ferguson is a conservative historian
brilliant brilliant brilliant guy if you
haven't seen my episode with him it's
one of my real favorites the guy's just
a tour de force of information and he's
married to ayaan Hirsi Ali by the way
and this is a Karlin Home Companion by
Kelly Carlin who is a big-time
progressive lefty one of my one of my
best friends a sweet girl daughter of
George Carlin who was a lefty comic and
a free-speech warrior then we have dirty
daddy by Bob Saget comedian lefty
liberal I had dinner with him and and
his wife and and David two weeks ago and
Bob is bob is a lefty and we debate all
sorts of things and it's all good then
nick Christakis who is a lefty he was on
the show recently he was the the Yale
professor who got yelled at because he
his wife basically wrote a letter saying
to the students of Yale that you know
you should be able to wear whatever
Halloween costume you want you might
want to take into account what people
might think but you know you can write
it and he defended his wife and then he
got called all sorts of things but
definitely the lefty liberal yeah dad a
one of my favorite guests and good
friend who is a behavioral psychologist
up in Canada who's I would say an
old-school liberal the strange death of
Europe by by Douglas Murray I feel about
giving away Lifetime Achievement Awards
right now the strange death of Europe by
Douglas Murray who is a British
Conservative really within the classical
liberal tradition I would say then a lot
of people have asked me about these
videos these are old stand-up tapes VHS
and I think it's mini DV tapes tons of
old stand-up stuff that I've done that
maybe will digitize one day
and [ __ ] and then what else do we have
here we have the moral arc by skeptic
comm founder Michael Shermer who I would
say basically is a class of a liberal /
libertarian hate by nadine strossen the
former head of the n-double a-c-p who's
a absolute free speech advocate lefty
her entire life Sam Harris who's a good
old-fashioned atheist liberal Jordan
Peterson who I would say basically you
guys all know Jordan I mean I would say
he's basically a classical liberalism
with some conservative beliefs when it
comes to maybe some of the religious
stuff but by no means a far-right
extremist Dennis Prager who I would say
is just like a dyed-in-the-wool
old-school sort of Reagan conservative
Andrew Clavin I kind of put him in the
in the Prager school right there your
ROM has Oney who I had on couple weeks
ago who wrote this wonderful book called
the virtue of nationalism which I've if
you haven't seen that interview I would
say check that one out because the word
nationalism has been so screwed up and
confused and conflated lately to imply
that it means some sort of race that it
has a racial element to it that if
you're a nationalist that means you're a
racist and it's just not true and he
explains that well thomas saul
discrimination and disparities maybe
that may be the most my personal
favorite interview I've ever done with
this 85 year old legend who's been
talking about economics and race and all
of these things for gosh for 50 years we
did that interview up at Stanford he
doesn't do much traveling they actually
invited us up there to do one again we
couldn't do it so hopefully hopefully
we'll be able to soon enough I've David
Horowitz the black book of the American
left David Horowitz definitely on the
right I would say he's sort of more
maybe a little bit more of a
neoconservative type but a former lefty
parents for communists and then and you
know he's sort of people who always say
well Ruben is sort of the next version
of Horowitz because Horowitz was a lefty
his whole life and then and during the
Reagan re-election I guess that's 84 so
in about 83 he decided to vote for
Reagan and and I come out basically as
as not a lefty and then finally the
right side of history that Ben Shapiro
fella that that fast talk in Orthodox
Jew who is who is a conservative without
question anyway the point is I don't
think you've seen
racists up here in this is just this is
just a random sampling you know it mean
we did this based on color and that
isn't to say I haven't talked to people
that perhaps have some sort of racist
element or anything like that it's a
it's all just sort of a silly nonsense
and it really shows you how the Overton
Window has shifted in such a crazy way
that if you talk to anyone who falls
outside of the the progressive group
think of the day which that's all that
this thing is if you talk to anyone who
is him as woke as the next guy then
they'll come and get you so I guess that
that does lead us to this situation with
Project Veritas and look here's the
situation
first off I've had James O'Keefe on the
show and you can you can say whatever
you want about James O'Keefe inand and
he's sort of fest up to doing some
somewhat shaky things in the past and
and all of those things so I don't want
to make this really about him or a
referendum on what you think of pride
Veritas or O'Keefe I mean they just in
the last two hours released an email
from a Google employee where they're
literally referring to Ben Shapiro
Orthodox viewing yarmulke wearing ben
shapiro
as a nazi they're referring to Prager
you written by you know I would say
conservative Jewish radio host Dennis
Prager written by it's you know he runs
the whole thing Prager you Dennis Prager
they refer to him as a Nazi they refer
to Jordan Peterson as a Nazi I mean
these things are so patently absurd they
for some reason they left me off that
that email list I was kind of offended
I've been called these things so many
times it's like oh guys what happened
you know what are you doing here um but
you know I want to talk about Jordan for
a second specifically on this because
you guys know I was on tour with Jordan
for most of 2018 we did a about 120
stops in something like 15 countries or
something and Jordan gives a different
lecture every single night so if those
of you that didn't see any of our shows
and hopefully in 2020 as we both have
new books coming out we'll jump back on
tour we'll see about that
you know basically the way it would work
is I would go on stage we'd be at these
awesome theaters three four or five
thousand people I go on stage for
usually about 10 or 15
I get everybody laughing I talk about
Lobster is some funny references to the
IDW crew just making everybody you know
look around and realize you're not on
YouTube right now you're having fun in
an in a room full of truly different
diverse in the right sense of diverse
people and all of those things and then
Jordan every single night truly guys
every single night would give a
different lecture he never gave the same
a lecture twice I've said this before
sometimes he would do all 12 rules talk
about all of them some nights he would
do a whole lecture on one rule he talked
about three rules some nights he would
just talk about YouTube some nights he
talked about podcast sometimes he would
talk about politics some nights he we
talk about relationships some nights he
would talk about Pinocchio I mean it was
completely different every night but one
of the things that was consistent that I
would say 90% of the shows is he would
go out of his way to condemn the
collectivist ideology that would lead
someone to fascism that would lead
someone to Nazism that would lead
someone to some of this all right stuff
he would do it every single night so the
idea that the New York Times and that
and YouTube and the rest of it that
there are people there that think these
things about these people it's not that
they really force oh yeah they were
calling them Nazis not just saying they
lead people to becoming Nazis right
they're calling them Nazis it's the most
patently absurd truly offensive cultural
appropriation for the people that hate
cultural appropriation they're
appropriating some some evil sick [ __ ]
so it's it's all just twisted and and
what we're finding out right now is that
if you fall outside of that mainstream
leftist nonsense that Google has decided
to put their finger down and and you
know suppress the video views that
you're gonna get and potentially
suppress other search things and all
sorts of things I mean I think we're
just at the tip of the iceberg I do want
to say though for for the Google
employees that are watching this and I'm
sure that there are and for Facebook
employees and Twitter employees well
first of the dam is breaking and a lot
of people are reaching out to all sorts
of people and I think these things have
just grown too large to protect
themselves but I just want to say like
it's actually it's not that fun having
to fight Google like everything being a
goal yeah I got something to talk about
with you guys right now this feels real
and like there's like a certain like
you know excitement around or something
like that but like everything being
equal I would rather do my interview
show do some live streams write my book
do some stand-up tour or whatever the
hell else I'm doing in my life and not
and just put videos up and then have
them treated fairly by the algorithm and
let the views be good or bad or for
wherever they may and I understand
there's some need for an algorithm
because there's so much information and
so much content to sort and all of those
things but if we're being manipulated
without knowing it's something that that
most of us from Crowder to Shapiro to
jp2 you know Eric Weinstein who doesn't
create specifically on YouTube but it's
obviously in the midst of all of this
thing and created the phrase
intellectual dark web it's like all of
us because we're a little outside of
that thing none of us have the people I
just mentioned none of these people have
extreme political views they have
varying political views they have
diverse political views but all of us I
know would prefer to just make content
and if you like it and you subscribe to
it but it's gonna show up in your feed
and if you don't like us you won't be
suggested our videos and whatever else
but this thing has become it's become
just such like a really really awful
like this thing strikes me as evil
what's happens there are people like I'm
not saying it's a giant conspiracy you
know it's funny there were people
yesterday that we're tweeting about how
oh you know Rubens but people keep
calling Ruben a conspiracy theorist the
last two years that Google is
manipulating things and you know bla bla
bla and it's like yesterday they were
kind of like well maybe a Rubens not
totally crazy I would prefer not to be a
conspiracy theorist I would prefer that
they were just transparent about their
their rules and then we would go do it I
also want to address real quick you know
this idea of that you're not allowed to
complain if you don't want government
involvement because you know I don't
want government involvement even right
this moment and hopefully after this if
you have a little time later you'll
watch some of my livestream from
yesterday where I talked to free-market
guys about what the alternatives are I
don't want the government involved even
the ID you know we can talk about the
platform versus publisher thing and I
think there's some interesting things
there that we could talk about antitrust
we can talk about all of those different
ways that government could get involved
to try to fix this but you know once you
start
using government power for something
then more and more government power just
keeps in croce and and the Trump
administration may be friendly to some
of those outsider voices right now but
he's not going to be President forever
even though you know if you watched
MSNBC I think they think he and I
announced he's gonna be king for two
hundred years he's not gonna be
president forever and once you give that
power to the government okay so the
government's gonna have power over the
tech companies and now let's say we have
a lefty government and now we have left
the tech companies while that then
you're really screwed and I don't even
want to make this a left-right thing
because I don't think that that's really
the right way to to frame it we really
have just sort of a we have a freedom
principle and you have to decide which
side you're on and I don't mean that
whether you're on the left side of it
the right side but you have a freedom
principle and I want people to be as
free as possible so what I would always
want is competition now I'm working on
some tech stuff
Jordan's working on some stuff there are
tons of people who have reached out to
me we have we have had insiders from
these companies that want to come work
for us now so I started a tech company
there there's all sorts of cool things
happening right now and as big as these
companies feel and as as monstrous as
they feel it's like I believe what I
still believe right now if if Susan
would Ricky is that her name or is that
that was Ricky from transformers that
was what's his name in transformers wiki
is that her name whatever our name is
Susan if you're watching this from
YouTube or if anyone's in the office
right now or if the janitors just got
the screen on right now if anyone's
working over there at Google right now
and you're freaking help because why is
Ruben talking about this stuff I would
love to just sit down with you no agenda
I won't bring notes I'm not gonna try to
get you have I ever tried to do that
once I'll treat you the same way I treat
all of my guests and let's talk this
thing out I just want the company to be
a little more transparent about what's
going on and I said I would suspect that
if you guys are depressing view counts
on certain things that means you're
depressing the ability to generate ad
revenue on it and your shareholders
might want to know about that so I think
they're just creating a whole series of
problems for themselves but it's just
absolutely unnecessary III just don't
believe it to be necessary I think that
there's so many ways that this could be
that this could be dealt with oh I
should also just real quick
you know when Crowder got into the hot
water two weeks ago when he got into
that fight with this Vox guy and they
were trying to ban Crowder that sounded
like he was at least gonna be
temporarily banned and the rest of it
you know we all came to his defense your
daily wire and Emblaze TV so Crowder's
in that blaze and Shapiro's on on daily
wire obviously they did bonkers some of
their best days ever of subscriptions
and I really do believe that that the
next version of the Internet and I do
see you guys throwing in some super
chats here and I really do appreciate
that so thank you
the next version of that is you'll just
figure out how to follow and support
creators directly and that'll be it so
we may be going into kind of unbundling
phase of the Internet that's kind of
what I believe right how I'm a maybe
these platforms have just become too big
I hope they aren't I love all doing all
this you know we can all we can all
complain about these things and all that
but how cool is all of this like
wherever you are in the world right now
I'm able to communicate with you you're
able to send me messages via Twitter
you're able to fight with anonymous
strangers and call everyone a Nazi and
you know make offensive gave remarks you
can do all of those things via the
Internet this cool tool that we all have
and yet what comes with that cool tool
is cool tools that should be a book or
something but what comes with that is
that you're gonna see people you don't
like you're gonna hear voices you don't
like and all of those things and what's
happening unfortunately is the
mainstream media the New York Times and
CNN and the rest of it they've decided
that if anyone gets any information they
don't like that they must be bad guys
and they must be silenced and that's the
weird thing so think about it this way
you know when you see all these articles
from box and HuffPo and then Media
Matters and all these things they're
always trying to censor everybody say
everyone's an alright Nazi let's get
Tucker Carlson's advertisers off and all
of this nonsense right when when was the
last time you saw say me and Prager
Bureau at Peterson or Rogan or Sam
Harris or the Weinsteins or any of these
people what was the last time you saw
any of these people try to get anyone
booted from anything you don't you just
don't you might say in some case I can't
think of one off the top of my head you
might say oh well there's somebody to go
protest or something like that like for
example when Linda Sarsour was invited I
think it was to City College in New York
I I am I've been very public about what
I think about this person I think she's
really I think she's a dangerous
character let's say but if the school
has invited her then the school it is on
the school it is the school's
responsibility to let her speak
you can go protest or now you can't pull
fire alarms you can't call in bomb
threats and and violently protest as has
been done to me and has certainly been
done to Shapiro and others but why is it
that this this mob 2d platform people to
silence people always is coming from one
direction and it's not coming from the
other direction that's something just
worth we're thinking about so so real
quick I want to just thank all of you
that are subscribed to us right now so a
if you're just subscribed here and you
check out what I'm doing and you share
it that's that that's really the most
important thing that you can do if you
think I'm a decent guy and that we're
trying to have decent conversation
around here and there's a there's a
whole world well everyone where
everyone's trying to destroy each other
and and I really don't try to do that
and I try not to talk about people I try
to talk about ideas to the best of my
ability and it's not always perfect but
that is what I try so but if you just
subscribe to this and you share these
videos and hopefully if you talk about
some of these ideas if you care about
them you talk about them with your
family and friends then you've done your
part but I do have to give a particular
serious and and just as grateful as I
could possibly beat up anyone the people
that subscribe to Dave Rubin comm /
donate that subscribed monthly you can
give whatever you want you get an
ad-free podcast for now we are building
outs and tears on that and trust me
we're building out some seriously cool
stuff and it just takes a little bit of
time but I started another company we
got some investment I don't take any
personal money out of that zero dollars
it's to build something that will build
in and it's really cool and we're
working with some cool people but you
guys enable us whether if YouTube look
if YouTube actually shut off all of our
D monetization tomorrow we'd still be
okay and that is because of you guys but
it does make you know building a
functional business heart because when
you watch your Reb go like this all the
time it's like well how do you how do
you decide how to hire how do you do a
one-year projection to your projection
everything else so I'm incredibly
appreciative obviously to you guys Dave
Rubin comm / donate if you dig it and
and if you don't you know if you just
share the videos that's good too so
anyway one of the things that we found
out through this
this Veritas video you know they've
released a couple things yesterday not
just this email that talks about Prager
& Shapiro had beaters and being Nazis
also just played out this the word Nazi
like how much more do you guys want to
destroy like a truly horrific historic
event talking about the Holocaust
talking about World War two the way you
guys throw around the term Hitler and
Nazis and all of these things and now
concentration camps there's such a twist
there's such a weird thing the people
who are who are so sensitive over words
and pronouns and all of this stuff the
way they twist words and use labels and
and twist history it's an erasure of
history actually it's pretty that's
actually gross and racist if I can dare
quote Batman
so we we have to figure out a better way
to get through some of this some of this
nonsense and and I think there is a way
to do it and I think the way to do it is
just by being honest with people I
really do and if you if you show people
that you're a little better you know
that's one of the questions I get a lot
of these Q&A is I did so in the last
month or so I haven't done too many
public gigs because I've been really
crunched down working on the book I'm
about 80% done now and I and it's and I
think it'll be officially announced on
August 1st it'll go on sale in May of
2020 and I promise you I've put my heart
and soul into this thing and I think
it's gonna be really good and different
and all that stuff but one of the things
I get asked always I did two gigs in the
last couple days so I was in Cleveland
at O'Connor yesterday I'm in two days
before I was at William Jessup
University which is a I think they
define themselves as a Christian liberal
arts college so it was really
interesting place to be and you know
people always say well what can I do
what can I do how do I get involve in
and really the only answer to that is
just start speaking up there there are
so many people that would love to
silence you and they have no problem
speaking up and if you think that
someone else is gonna speak up on your
behalf if you won't speak up it's like
that's why there's so few of us and you
know I also been thinking about this as
as you know I've been on tour with
Jordan for the for the year you know he
talked about the importance of
stories right he often uses he sometimes
he talks about the story you know a
story like Pinocchio or something like
that but he talks about biblical stories
and he obviously does his biblical
lectures and it's like one of the
stories that keeps ringing in my head
right now is the story of David versus
Goliath now I'm not gonna give you a
full biblical breakdown I leave that to
Jordan I don't know if he's done one on
David versus Goliath I hope he has and
if he hasn't I'm gonna ask him to do one
but the but you all know the basics of
the story which is that David who was
this this little guy was able to take
out Goliath who was this Goliath right
this big giant monster and and David did
it with just I think it was just a
slingshot right and it's like maybe that
is the message we're all supposed to be
getting right now we think that these
big bag tech companies are unstoppable
and whatever but if we just use our
voices maybe we can change things I
really believe that so for the engineers
at Google watching this if you're not
happy speak up a little bit I met an
engineer yesterday I met a Google
engineer yesterday and he's like you
know we're not bad people we're kind of
you know we're not in there to
manipulate things and take people down
and destroy things but then the culture
of it starts getting weird and people
start being silent you let things slide
on the rest of it it's like I get it but
but maybe we can maybe we can change
things I think we can okay quick
reminder click the bell there's a bell
click clack Bell click the Bell and make
sure you have all notifications on that
way you actually see my videos when they
come out I should also tell you that one
of the things we're thinking about so so
I've had a whole bunch of offers
obviously to take this show elsewhere to
be produced by other people people have
offered to buy a portion of the show
gajillion things and I don't want to do
any of those things we've turned away
some pretty significant money to do
things like that
I have been thinking about some other
ways to sort of protect our digital
property so I mentioned this tech
company I'm doing but I think there are
some other ways through distribution and
I think we'll probably make some
announcements within the next couple
weeks related to that because I do think
having having your stuff as long as I
can control it right as long as I can do
the show the way I want as long as I'm
my boss I run I'm running the company
and the rest of it I think getting our
stuff out there in as many places as
possible is a good idea so we've been
thinking about some some distribution
stuff oh I am being told that if you if
you see a whole Bell
if you click it and then you put the you
click the whole Bell you'll get all
notifications if you have a hollow Bell
you're only gonna get some of the
notifications I mean I guess do they
make this intentionally obtuse like
what's the point what's the point if you
subscribe to something you probably want
to see the videos but the way they're
rejiggering the order of everything and
you know the other part of this is you
know that New York Times article that
came out and I know I've talked about
this bit well it wasn't just that they
were implying that we lead people far
right which is just crazy because I get
more email from conservatives that say
you know I'm a little more liberal
because of watching you I get far more
of that than anyone saying I've seen
maybe two emails where someone was like
I became one actually I've never seen
one but I could envision something like
someone saying I or something like I
can't even really think about it
something like I became more right
because of you I honestly can't think of
one I truly can I'm not I'm not
bullshitting I honestly can but one of
the things in the New York Times really
the New York Times article was this idea
that we're radicalizing people to the
right even though in the article itself
this youtuber ends up being a lefty so
the whole article is debunked by itself
but the point is through this veritas
thing is that what they what the insider
said basically is that they have tagged
this channel as right-wing and then what
that what they then do is they sort of
press their thumb in suppressing the
suggested video tab so that instead of
suggesting more of my videos or things
that you might be interested in sort of
in line with that they then suggest CNN
or MSNBC videos now again as a private
company I suppose they can do whatever
they want right but the question is are
they only doing this one way if you were
to watch far lefty stuff which there's a
ton of on YouTube that most of it's
pretty craptastic if you were to watch
that would they then try to push you to
more centrist or right leaning things I
think we obviously know the answer to
that is no so it's not but saying
something is right leaning or right-wing
inherently is bad I don't believe it to
be bad I think that's one of the things
I've one of the reasons I get so much
[ __ ] is because what I have done is I've
actually talked to conservatives and
right-leaning people and libertarians
and treated them as humans I don't think
that's frickin rocket science I think I
think they are humans and in most cases
I found them to be much more tolerant
than them so-called tolerant people
but I think that's why I get the amount
of [ __ ] I get because not only have I
sort of escaped left this lunacy but
I've also treated these people I've sat
here with Shapiro and respectfully
disagreed on his religious views on gay
marriage for example and my favorite one
of those my favorite example of this is
was it in May or no no I think it was in
January we did we did are one of our
last shows one of our last Peterson
shows for this run and we were at the
Orpheum here in LA which is a great
theater downtown about 3,000 seats
really cool old-school theater and I
said Ben because it was in LA lives here
I said hey why don't you I'll do my
thing at the top of the stage top of the
show sorry I'm getting crazy pop-ups
here I said I'm gonna do my thing to top
the show and why don't I bring you out
prodigal nuts whatever and I do my thing
and then I said a special guest Ben
Shapiro and Ben brought out a little
cupcake and handed me a cupcake because
you know we've had this ongoing thing
that we're friends but he has a
religious belief around gay marriage and
he wouldn't bake me a gay wedding cake
and that's okay and I don't want Ben's
kosher cake okay it's completely fine
with me
does that does that difference of
opinion create a situation that that Ben
will never be my like true best friend
in life yeah but can we be friends can
we can we respect each other mutually
can we agree to disagree
I've said this before but I do believe
that over the course of time 50 years
from now if we're able to maintain that
conversation I believe that probably at
80 something years old you gotta go you
know Dave you were married to your
husband for you know 50 some odd years
and you guys turned out to be pretty
decent I think maybe I was wrong on that
one I suspect that's the way this thing
would go maybe I'm wrong maybe not only
one way to find out and that's through a
little tolerance right so anyway so I
bring Shapiro on stage the crowd goes
completely bananas right they're like
holy caddies two are up there together
the cake was funny the whole thing he
did a really funny impression of Jordan
talking fast doing the hand thing the
whole thing and I thought here we are in
a room here are two people with
fundamentally different view on life
that really of different that have
deeply deeply different views in a
certain way right but here we are you
know sort of breaking bread together
breaking cake together so to speak and
thousands of people are applauding it
and then you know some of the video got
posted on Twitter and then I see all
these progresses I mean hundreds of the
tolerant progressives who love diversity
and all that stuff
Ben Ben's a homophobe and Reubens a
self-hating gay and it's like you guys
you guys are the tolerant ones I think I
think you're doing this thing wrong so I
just think what's happening right now is
the narrative is being flipped in
real-time and you know you could even
look at somebody like Candace Owens now
Candace is my friend we had her and her
fiance over for dinner a couple weeks
ago I did Candace's show and Praeger you
not too long ago in Candace and I
absolutely have different tactics when
it comes to things you know I said to
Candace it's like I swallowed the red
pill and she snorted it right like she's
definitely more aggressive than I am she
she's a sort of more more direct puncher
where I I would go maybe for a little
more nuance or conversation or something
but it's like where everyone's different
we all act differently in people that
people are like Ruben you better you
better get her in line as if I own her
or something and it's like this always
comes from the tolerant lefties it's
really bizarre but I think what's
happening is we're seeing the narrative
shift so the reason I mention Candace
it's like Candace for the last year she
really broke through at another level
and then there was this the Kanye West
thing and all that and then it's like
what what's happening to the Democrats
now now they're all about reparations
because all her whole message of black
people don't have to be Democrats which
anyone in their right mind would think
about the color of your skin should not
dictate what what political position you
have right unless there was a party that
was voted that was trying to take away
your rights which there is not I hate to
tell you that people there isn't but
it's like now they're all about
reparations she said black people don't
to be Democrats another literally want
to give reparations well no one in my
family ever owned slaves why would why
would I even if someone in my family
didn't own slaves like am i guilty of
the sins of not even my father my
grandfather my great-grandfather
etcetera etcetera like my
great-grandparents and great-great
grandparents came from Eastern Europe
with nothing like like this whole idea
so now if they want to do that then then
you saw this Elizabeth Warren now wants
to give gay reparations yes I am NOT
making this up she literally if you
think she's tweeted out this thing that
gay people because they couldn't get
married lost fifty million dollars in
blah blah blah I've never heard gay
people say they want gay reparations
I have never heard it I showed it to
David the other day and he was like what
what like what like this is just bananas
but they're being reduced to only free
cotton oh now free college for everybody
or no no well free college yeah Bernie
ones free college but then the other one
is now debt forgiveness right they're
gonna wipe cancel all debt
can't swallow college debt well that's
something you know we just paid off
David's remaining college loans why did
we do that are we gonna get that money
back I'd like that money back or should
we go back 20 years and people should be
rewarded for things that they did or did
not do so for example when I was in high
school my dad sat me down he made it
very clear we lived in New York New York
has a pretty robust state college so
SUNY State University of New York and
they have Buffalo and Albany and Oneonta
and Stony Brook Binghamton Geneseo a
whole bunch of schools my dad said to me
if you go to a state school there
they're significantly cheaper so I'm
more than happy to pay for it and if you
want to go out of state you have to pay
for it so I looked at my options and I
was like you know what I'm gonna go to
SUNY Binghamton SUNY Binghamton is a
spectacular school by the way
very close to Cornell and it's sort of
similar in academic sense as Cornell so
what you would get at Binghamton often
were the Cornell level students who just
didn't have the money to get into
Cornell and this is by the way one of
the reasons that I believe in in in
public education and I do believe that
there is reason to for the school
schools to be funded by public I you
know that is a use of government to me
state government for the most part but
since I made that choice well I guess if
we're giving money out to people I want
some of that I would have made a
different choice maybe maybe I would
have gone to a I wanted to go to Indiana
just really to watch basketball or you
know some other school like maybe I you
should I get some of that money back
because or like it's just the system of
like pressuring and punishing people for
all the wrong reasons and then so you're
gonna tell me that people everyone's
gonna have to pay to forgive this
students loan all these middle class and
upper middle class students who went to
schools that they couldn't really get to
but because they had tons of money they
could go now you're gonna take money
from people who didn't go to college
let's say or who or who paid off their
loans to pay off other people so it's
the whole thing is bananas but all of
this I bring this up because the whole
freaking thing is in flux right now
everything is being debated and argued
of
and it's like every time I hear another
politician say we want to give you this
black people you're gonna get
reparations gay people you're gonna get
rape you're gonna get free free college
we're we're just gonna brainwash you
into thinking that you need free college
etc it's there all of these things I'm
just like there any politician who could
just be like I don't want anything to do
with you people
that would be my kind of politician if
there was a politician who was like you
know I really don't want to bother you
I'm gonna you know make sure that the
the borders are safe and you know some
minimal stuff make sure the states
aren't boring and a couple other things
but beyond that you know live your life
we'll make sure the roads are okay we'll
make sure we've got some hospitals we
can talk about you know if States want
to do health care and a bunch of other
stuff that would be a great I would vote
for that guy you know what I keep
thinking do you guys see the movie
Brewster's Millions with with Richard
Pryor it's a spectacular movie Brewster
gets he's that he's a struggling
baseball player for like a third like a
triple-a team or double a team called
the Hackensack Bulls he's a pitcher John
Kennedy is the is the catcher and in it
he finds out that he has a dead relative
who was worth a ton of money and the guy
says to him in the it's played by Hume
Cronyn great actor that's a good
reference I just got that and in his
will his living you know living well so
he does a video he says I'm gonna give
you thirty million dollars but money
ruined my life so you have to spend that
thirty million dollars in one month and
if you do you get three hundred million
dollars and that's what the movies about
it's a really hilarious movie and Pryor
is just process the best of the best and
I love John Candy why the hell am I
telling you about this oh because one of
the ways he does it's not just to talk
about Richard Pryor in John Candy
although I rather do that probably one
of the things that he decides is that
he's gonna run for mayor because he's in
New York City and he sees that the
Democrat is awful and the Republicans
awful and they're corrupt and they're
almost in on it together and he runs a
campaign I can't remember what the exact
slogan is is it is it don't vote for me
or don't vote for any of these guys or
don't something like that somebody will
remember it in the comments section I'm
sure and he pours a ton of money into
just saying don't vote for any of us
we're all freaking awful
that's the guy I would like to vote for
so I don't I don't know where that guy
is but anyway what else am I telling you
so I will be so it's 3:30 right now I'm
getting picked up in about a half hour I
got a jump on Tucker where I'm sure we
will well I know for a fact we're gonna
talk about all of these things oh and I
should know you know this is another one
of those cases where every time I do fox
news people say why don't you go on CNN
why don't you go on MSNBC they've never
asked by the way when I go on Tucker
it's live they never tell me what to say
I don't tell them what I'm gonna say or
anything like that doesn't mean I agree
with everything Tucker says or what the
previous guest said or any of that stuff
but there is this this odd thing that if
you go on there you're a bad guy or
something like that and it's like come
on guys like there's such a realignment
happening and let's none of the above
thank you thank you who did that Jackson
Thomas thank you sir the campaign slogan
for Richard Pryor in Brewster's Millions
is none of the above just don't fall for
any of us it's a great great movie
I've been thinking about maybe doing
like a movie night and trying to
incorporate that into doing a video
somehow something like that I mean I got
to think that through a little bit more
but anyway I still I think you guys
understand my preference would be that
Susan would Ricki Sam Witwicky whoever
come on the show let's just talk about
this freaking thing Jack from Twitter
for years every few months we would
message me and say he'd be happy to do
the show he won't respond to me anymore
it's I don't even mean to make it about
this like inner inside baseball dribble
but they're putting us in these weird
positions where it's like you're making
it you're making us seem like bad guys
and you know we're not bad guys and it's
like you actually might be the bad guy
so you know that's I think that's about
it for now so what I will tell you just
one more time as all of these things
you're getting nutty the way to support
the people that you like really is by is
by subscribing to them and if you give a
couple bucks a month or whatever you can
do that is the way to directly subscribe
to people I've thought many times in the
last couple months I've even said it to
my guys and they're like you're an idiot
I've said like out of protest maybe we
would just shut YouTube ads off
altogether and it's just too much even
even when it's down it's still too much
of what our
monthly income is but I've thought about
doing it out of principle but I don't
know maybe if we got to some level of
subscription I would do it
you know the counter to that is that I
do like that the more success you have
the more you make like I like that
incentive structure so the more views we
get that means I'm doing something
relevant so that we make more money on
it there's there's screw there's a sort
of it whacked out incentive structure
there too because then it's like I could
just do stuff for clicks but I think you
guys know the way we treat the channel
as I've talked about many times it's not
purely just for clicks and we don't we
don't play that game and by the way we
also have we've hired a YouTube YouTube
pro I don't know if he wants me to say
his name right now so I won't who's gone
in and done a whole audit of our channel
and last month then we are making little
little changes on the margins and
figuring out some things on the back end
to figure out how to how to how to just
reach you guys I mean the whole point is
we want to reach you guys again because
we now have over a million subscribers
and they're making it harder and harder
for us to reach you oh and I should note
that it wasn't just this one insider who
said this thing about Ruben and Tim
Poole and a couple others being tagged
right-wing and that that then is put in
the algorithm to suppress our reach and
shut us down and suggested videos they
also got this this girl who since has
deleted her Twitter account so that
might tell you something who is a high
level like chief diversity officer type
thing at Google and they got her
basically saying that Google wasn't
gonna let Trump win another election in
effect
I'm loosely quoting we're not gonna let
that happen again nobody was drawing the
line in the sand so we decided to and
it's like when they talk about diversity
they're not talking about real diversity
nobody cares nobody cares what color you
are nobody cares what gender you are
what sexuality you are we don't want the
government coming in and saying what
pronouns we can use we don't want the
government coming in and saying who we
can and can't hire and all of these
things that's it so I suspect that more
and more leaks are coming because once
people see a little bit of it then I
think some of the employees there I'll
get a little bit braver but again I just
really want to be clear about this like
if you're watching and you're a big shot
at Google or you're you're on the board
at Facebook or you know your share
one of these things or something it's
like trust me I am sitting here as a guy
that that does this that would prefer
tomorrow for it all to just kind of
reset and we're gonna just put your
videos up they're gonna go out to your
people we're not gonna mess with things
we're gonna do things a little more
honestly we're gonna just like Google
like just have your meal Copa have your
meal Copelan like we'll let up it's not
you know like it's fun in a way this is
the catch-22 of it it's like I do feel a
certain energy right now and I think you
guys feel it and it's like it's cool in
life to like have that like fight to go
after and all of that kind of stuff but
everything being equal like I'd love to
talk about ideas the way that we do I'd
love to keep interviewing people to the
best of my ability and you know and let
the chips fall where they may
okay I have to go and get changed and
get ready for Tucker
we'll save one more you know and I'll
give you a little quick little insider
studio tour so this is my garage I've
done this a couple times for you guys
first off we'll say hi to Hema I don't
think she's moved Emma check in with the
good people all right we're just we're
chilling we're relaxing right now all
right
it's all good so so this is the studio
so in there right there so that's that's
the control room so we built this this
window into there so my guys basically
can can yell at me when I screw up
something and that's where you know the
TriCaster is and all the computer
monitors and server and all that kind of
stuff so all my whole crew works in
there when we're when we're shooting the
show this is a monitor if I have to
clean up those wires sorry about that I
know if I've learned anything about
doing live things on YouTube people are
obsessed with if you have a wire out of
place why haven't you fixed that we just
put this up so so we have that there we
have a giant map that is a giant map
from Ikea I don't want to brag but yes
that's a map from Ikea and then we have
you know our cameras and those great
things so those are sound panels which
we have tons of I don't know if you can
see all that I think you should be able
to write panels which were were donated
by a fan if you're watching Warren thank
you again my friend
and this is our lighting grid if you
want to if you guys are ever building a
studio for yourself you will learn very
quickly that that lighting is by far the
most expensive piece of it so we have
this huge giant grid up there and all
sorts of lights which burn really hot so
we have to we have to keep the a/c on
pretty it pretty intensely a fan just
sent us these I wish I could remember
his name off the top of my head but sent
us a bunch of these it's really cool
this is made out of wood really cool
American flags and as you may have seen
in the control room we have a giant flag
which is from like 1950 I think it's
from Virginia or something and also if
you can maybe see what else has gone on
there we've got the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution yeah I
am a real right-wing maniac obsessed
with freedom I know and and I'll just
give you a little close-up of some of
the artwork so this painting and and
most of the artwork in my house actually
was done by cailin rosa Janet ta y li n
Rose Janet and you can go to her website
I think it's Caitlyn Rose Janet Khan
she's a fantastic artist this is a piece
we commissioned and she knows that I
love coffee so some of the there's
actual coffee grinds and you're actually
giving it some texture so that's that's
that one and then she did the the I
guess you'd call that the the sister
piece behind the guests over there and
is there anything else to show you in
here I think that's about it well I give
you so these are like the mics the
microphones and that kind of stuff and
you know some more lighting stuff and
maybe next time I'll do a little tour of
I'll do a tour of the the control room
maybe I'll show you guys into the green
room and you can see all the video games
that I let people play when they're here
and the rest of it anyway so that's it
thank you guys
yeah we'll just keep going and see what
happens but again Susan from YouTube I'd
love to talk to you I see that you
respond to people on Twitter by the way
you seem to respond to other Creators
and and invite them out for coffee and
tea and all of that I do have a million
subscribers but if you don't want to
talk to me I saw ben shapiro invited you
on so if you want to chat with ben that
would be great too
i'm happy to talk to anyone at these
companies is there is there a trust and
safety person that wants to talk in
terms a service person that wants
you know the guy who cleans the windows
that would be fine too I'd be curious to
know how your day is going that would be
that would be all good so uh all right
people I'll be on Tucker I believe it is
at 8:10 p.m. this evening
tomorrow is my birthday so I have no
idea I know that there's something in
store for me tomorrow I don't know
exactly what it's gonna be
David surprised me last weekend actually
we did something really cool we drove up
to Modesto which is like a five or six
hour drive up from LA we drove to
Modesto and we got to see Frankie Valli
Frankie Valli and the four seasons
he's 85 years old and we got to see him
do his thing and sing all the the four
seasons greatest hits and some of his
solo stuff he's 85 and you know there's
there's definitely little lip-synching
involved no doubt about it but we had
great seats and I went right up to the
stage and I always loved Frankie Valli I
just watched Jersey Boys and thank you
guys for all the birthday messages I see
that but we just we just had a great
great time it was so much fun and it was
great like outdoor it was just really in
a field in the middle of nowhere and it
was just totally fun and just singing
along with music I'm old-school like
that I love Frankie Valli and then oh
and this is super super cool we were
driving home and I got a message from a
fan who was able to get two extra
tickets to Disney Star Wars Galaxies
edge so this is the new Star Wars theme
park that opened up at Disney
it isn't even open for the public yet
but he got us two tickets and we ended
up driving it end up being like a
eight-hour drive because we had to go we
went up to Modesto then we had to pass
the LA on the way back down and go
another like hour an hour and a half -
uh - where the hell it's at Anaheim and
we went to the Star Wars land and then
it was funny what happened so we wait
online and we get in and it was just
like just mobbed everywhere and they're
doing some really cool stuff there
because what they did was they created a
whole new land it's a whole new planet
so it's not like you're going to Hoth or
Tatooine or Alderaan well I guess you
can't cut all her apologies condolences
but it's a they created this whole new
world and there's no branding there so
if you buy a coca-cola it's in like
alien language and the water bottles are
in like another language and all
the people there all of the the workers
there they're basically in character the
whole time as if they're citizens of
this village so that was actually pretty
cool there's a first-order sort of
landing area and we saw extra Baca and
an x-wing then you get to fly the
Millennium Falcon but I just tell you
one more thing so we go to the
Millennium Falcon thing and the way they
do it you go into yeah sorry the people
of Alderaan I know that was offensive um
so we go to the Millennium Falcon and
you're in a group of like six or eight
people I was with four people total so
you're with some strangers and this guy
I want to get the guy in trouble this
one this won't get him in trouble but
I'm standing in the front and you know
we're standing in the Millennium Falcon
it looks like the myname Falcon it's so
cool we could play the game you know
like the monster chess game that they
have you can sit there at the board over
there or whatever the guy that's
supposed to give us the speech so he's
telling us what our mission is and it's
very important we're about to fly the
Millennium Falcon oh we got to save the
thing to do the thing and the whole
thing and the guy looks at me and he
completely blanks out and he kind of
walks away for a second I was like what
happened I thought he had like some kind
of like medical emergency or something
and it turned out that the guy
recognized me and he was a huge fan and
he literally forgot the script that he
was supposed to tell us and he's like he
started profusely apologizing to
everyone I'm such a huge fan I'm so
sorry I'm not supposed to do this I want
to get in trouble but anyway super nice
guy but it's pretty cool to be
recognized on the Millennium Falcon I
was like done something right in life
all right guys I gotta go I'll talk to
you later
see you tonight at 10 after 8:00 Eastern
on on Tucker Carlson and look this story
isn't going anywhere and it seems like
you guys are into these live streams we
should be doing more of these we'll
probably start doing them off the off
the studio camera and maybe I'll do some
handheld stuff on the road or something
but anyway All Things Considered
reminder I'm not a Nazi ben shapiro
nodded let's just do the quick not a
Nazi list Dave Rubin not a Nazi does not
like Nazis actually grew up around
Holocaust survivors on both sides of my
family and and all joking aside it's
well I'm writing about this in my book
but it's it's it's the worst sort of
perversion of history that you can do to
call someone like that so Dave Rubin not
a Nazi Ben Shapiro Orthodox Jewish
yarmulke wearing ben shapiro not a nazi
dennis prager not a Nazi jordan Peterson
not a Nazi Tim Poole not a Nazi steven
crowder not a Nazi these people have
political differences that seem to be a
little
different than what YouTube wants him to
have that's all people so let's leave it
at that
anyway have a great night everybody and
thank you guys for free Joe I see a lot
of good stuff happening in the chat I
think some good stuff it's mostly people
saying crazy things but I think there's
probably some decent people there but I
see a bunch of super chats jumped in and
again if you want to subscribe it's Dave
group and consolation donate Thank You
Emma let's take a walk
alright see you guys